Speaker 1: So I'm going to show you something
today, which is notable because it's a total
scam on two levels.
This is sort of rare.
Alex Jones still has a show, conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones.
He has a show.
It's not really appearing in many places because
he's been banned from YouTube, Facebook, I
think Spotify and others.
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones had
a complete and total meltdown over ivermectin.
OK, in the segment, Alex Jones purports to
take ivermectin for his audience to prove
to them it's safe and it's great.
Now, there are two scams here and I'm not
going to say either is more important to understand
than the other.
Both are really important to understand.
The first scam is that Alex Jones doing this
means anything about the safety and efficacy
of ivermectin for covid.
When we've actually looked at studies, there
are no actual Arktos double-blind Arktos randomized
controlled trials that tell us ivermectin
does anything good prophylactically or for
active treatment of covid.
You look at Joe Rogan, who took ivermectin
and six other things for something from which
most people recover anyway, right?
I mean, doesn't mean we don't take it seriously,
but most people recover.
And you see that he took ivermectin.
And as I throw my son and monoclonal antibodies,
all these different things, that's not anything
that doesn't that's nothing that doesn't tell
us anything.
When you look at actual studies, the study,
people tend to point to an ivermectin as an
Egyptian study where there was ivermectin
versus hydroxy chloroquine, no placebo group.
It's not rigorous.
It's just it's simply not rigorous.
So Alex Jones taking ivermectin on his show,
doesn't actually tell us anything.
Second part is it actually sort of looks like
Alex Jones only pretends to take the pills
and actually drops it under his desk and doesn't
even take the pill.
So it may be a scam on that level as well.
So let's start looking at the video and see
what we can make of it.
I would get the kids out of the room for this
one.
This is that's a disclaimer.
Let's let's go
Speaker 3: Caravedo.
A real shot, please.
You know what this is, this is ivermectin
for humans who won a Nobel Prize is an antiviral
and this is inhalable.
These are the tablets, steroids.
So let me show you.
Speaker 1: OK, so let's let's stop right there.
First of all, the steroid.
Why would you take a steroid unless you need
it?
Steroids are not prophylactic for viruses.
Steroids reduce inflammation, which is why
sometimes they're given.
We we were looking at dexamethasone.
When people have real lung compromised, you
give dexamethasone to reduce the inflammation
and maybe allow the lungs to heal.
But steroids suppress the immune system and
they can actually extend how long it takes
to clear the virus.
So why you would randomly take a steroid unless
you're sick and it's been prescribed steroids
have so many side effects from a mental health
standpoint.
They can cause mania, panic attacks, insomnia.
It's crazy, right, that the whole prednisone
is one of the things Rogen took.
And that's why that's why it's here.
But I think Alex Jones mostly focuses in on
the ivermectin.
So let's continue
Speaker 3: to do this anyways earlier.
See this?
Watch closely this.
Sure.
You see this Bill Gates.
I'm going to kill those pronouns, you bastard
murderers and hit with a bioweapon, you monster.
You want to suppress me?
You want to kill me, you son of a bitch, you
goddamn demon.
You think I'm easy to kill?
I think I'm going to roll over to your crap.
Speaker 1: So listen, I've looked at this
a few times, it does look to me like when
Alex Jones is making a big to do of grabbing
his water or beer or whatever he's using to
slug this, it looks like he's sort of just
drops the pill under his desk.
I don't know.
We'll look at it one more time and continue.
I think the point is whether he really took
it or not, it doesn't actually change anything
about ivermectin.
I think he might have dropped the pill below
his desk,
Speaker 3: you goddamn demon.
He's like, I'm easy to kill.
I think I'm going to roll over to your crap.
No, no, Joe Rogan kicked your mother and asked
who you love to bury him to, you little monster
maggot, he's in this National Geographic piece
about, oh, I don't usually deal with my enemies
right away.
I get them later.
Yeah.
You creep up on with a poison injection dressed
up in a lab coat.
Little Josef Mengele, Nuremberg Code violating
monster.
Speaker 1: So these are these are analogies
to Nazi experimenters in terms of public health
officials right now.
Speaker 3: Get damn monster.
Speaker 1: I don't know that he's really taken
the pill
Speaker 3: serial cancer proteins like that
Nobel Prize winning or humans, Nobel Prize
winning for humans, Nobel Prize winning for
Nobel Prize winning for humans.
Speaker 1: So here he's actually having what
appears to be a psychotic break.
Speaker 3: Nobel Prize Money for humans, 2005,
Nobel Prize winning for humans.
Oh, Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan.
You keep working to drink the horse.
Pretty stupid.
Oh, particularly from Alex Jones.
They're both so dumb.
They're both going to be dead.
Yeah.
That's why Joe's worth like three million
dollars.
Yeah, he's real stupid.
That's why he lives in a 60 million dollar
house on the river.
You left taking all the shots and dying the
masses.
He's the one that headlines with Dave Chappelle,
not you, your stupid.
And I sure wish you'd wake up, but you sit
there calling me stupid, an independent media
person that built the biggest independent
media operation in the world to change the
whole paradigm with my bad ass listeners and
you sit around and laugh at us.
Medical doctors gave that to me.
It is incredible.
It helped my family.
It helped me.
It helped everybody.
And it's approved for humans, for all sorts
of viral stuff.
But that never RSG doesn't want you to know
because he wants to plan it for himself and
he wants you dead.
Well, guess what?
Souce rolled over and dying so easily, you
little murder.
Speaker 1: OK, so that's pretty, pretty serious
stuff.
Now, imagine seeing that and saying, whoa,
you know what?
It it seems like a pretty logical thing to
take ivermectin based on what I saw.
And obviously no sensible person could watch
that and come away with that belief.
A complete and total meltdown from Alex Jones.
But unfortunately for the people that hear
him talk about his supplements and colloidal
silver and, you know, who knows what and they
buy that stuff.
It's not that different to hear him talk about
taking ivermectin and prednisone.
I mean, he might have been high on steroids.
That mania could be steroid induced mania
for all we know, if he's really taking it
for no reason.
So there's two scams here.
I already told you about them.
But then on top of that, there's the sort
of social tragedy, the public tragedy of people
who get medical advice from Alex Jones.
And it's it's just the sad state of affairs
for the country, folks.
Really, really sad state of affairs